what's up everyone that's right cringe
Tuesday's bringing it back it's Monday
whatever it doesn't matter I just want
to look at cringe bra come on I've
earned the right to look at cringe
this isn't Gothenburg I think I've been
in that place actually Oh God don't
answer let it ring don't answer
imagine if the ringtone came from this
stage the cellphone owner probably went
into hiding after this I'm chilling man
it's snowing here in Albuquerque and
everybody's bugging out no it doesn't
and they drive like it to shove on the
audio guys keep it up right of you oh
god it's such a long delay yeah I can't
watch it anymore
Aaron kiss Andy on the lips for 20 bucks
I'm not do you know what people will say
no you know he will say they will be
happy everyone else will be happy dude
for the people
I'll just give it to you right now oh no
brah brah
[Laughter]
this is pain she clearly had like an out
like a way to explain it like oh I can't
do it because people call me bad things
I love cringe so much thank you Andy
well at least someone scored Jesus
Christ
Wow dude had her twisting her hair yeah
maybe it worked I would say not cringe
on this one not cringe put it on the
screen say a quick question what do you
think about the whole black lives matter
movement that just came in here and
shots were fired what what happened well
what do you think about oh did you see
the protest earlier oh there was a
protest shots were fired what do you
think about the whole black side man
that's why we're here tonight
wow I did not even know about that but I
think that's pretty hardcore
are you a Jew Dana african-american no
but what I did yes yes I was why would
you cuz they're just like everybody you
know we're all equal we're all the same
what about a white you can repair those
are those your real eyelashes look I
like that oh thank you oh you are yeah
where you from uh well I was born in
Miami but I lived in Colombia for most
of my life Colombia yes
are you 18 no I'm 19 oh wow young do you
just move here
are you 18 a fighter 19 last time I met
someone is just 17 oh okay but you're
definitely cute do you work here
what do you do oh you don't know yeah I
mean I work at the Harbor are you how
you work in the street no no no no do
you have any more questions you can call
me later tonight I'll give you my card
call me alright take it there you have
it you're really cute I like you
are these real are you that's that on
national television god it makes me sick
see this is a one-of-a-kind piece
there's no other one like this
particular one in the world see the
tracks go this way and it's really cool
because it records much more accurately
but Oh
oh my god that does happen every once in
a while that can't be good you asked for
it
Oh video devoted to the rainbow sponge a
whole video arts and crafts department
sent me to Korea now not a normal sponge
this is so dense three sizes because I
can't stand just one size another thing
that I want to talk about is the hygiene
of the sponge I squeezed and squeezed
and squeezed and squeezed no flab on
this arm for my cleaning lab on this arm
now if you do get it on your hands
gloves are incredible I have a pure I
love a sponge that is absolutely pure
lips a virgin edge oh my gosh I'm sorry
I want you to look at all of those
Wiggles Wow
I love to wiggle the whole thing kind of
three of course you can go straight go
this way and it is so hard to stop was
amazing so that's this is what happens
when you retire oh my gosh Wiggles I've
seen this I love this place
i watch the show every day everybody has
issues with a lot of chatter back here
takes every one minute hope you enjoyed
your last time in the Today Show there's
so mad
Wow he should get a gold medal he
sacrifice himself for the greater good
the Hawaiian chair infomercial oh wow at
the office that looks so comfortable
going to a very busy work environment
let's get some first-time reactions
amazing on my abs I just really feel
this working Hawaii chair well answered
no joking about balancing
Zor filing paperwork you can hardly call
this work with the Hawaii chair it takes
the work out of your workday if you can
sit oh my god
imagine a boss firing an employee while
sitting on that sorry Jared it's not
working out for you we have to let you
go 1816 is he on this one and the nice
thing about these practice Katoch oh
that hurt big-time a piece of that jet
that tip just got me O'Dell
oh they'll do something oh that got me
good we may need emergency surgery in
the studio we may need emergency surgery
in the studio like me Oh probe citizen
or a citizen harassed she arrested
herself she did it oh how this is a
sport it's so weird it looks like she's
trying to participate that's great
[Music]
[Applause]
well my mission is done I don't know
what to do when your one job is taken
away from you it's not saluting he's
looking for the other symbol the salute
was symbolic the best recovery in his
theory of live performance Wimbledon
[Applause]
please call what helices jimmy kimmel
there's no charge the line God why are
tennis players such babies
tennis officials oh my god is the same
is it hey I want to see it I think it
actually was out there we go
that was out he's right
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Trisha Paytas insult even I need to see
this you're kind of the worst but that's
okay
what if I think you're the worst a lot
of people think you're the worst
bro you honey you had like a 90%
download on the trans video that doesn't
mean anything
yeah it sure does what I mean I mean it
means that you had a largely negative
reaction on the video
yeah doesn't mean I'm the worst well
being the worst is kind of an abstract
concept but I think it's a personal
belief that I think the people who smash
the dislike button thought you were the
worst
I don't think so I disagree all right
this is clearly me just watching YouTube
at this point I hope you guys enjoyed
some cringe with me
epic smash like if you enjoyed check out
another video see you guys tomorrow bye
bye well you haven't tried to pursue me
later citizen e after 50 million out
troops by etch my don't just down it's
still relevant just down a bit